marker with the funny new slave the head
nor hat
my name is George Motz my job is to make
sure you appreciate the regional
American burger that's right the
regional burger burgers that are rich in
history these are burgers that become
regional burgers because somebody in a
region decided to create that thing
doesn't make any sense trying to create
that thing the reason I become so deeply
interested in the American hamburger is
because of the original expression
original burger becomes a reflection of
the people and the traditions of that
part of the country the burgers that I
love in America are not the ones that
are cooked up in some corporate lab but
the ones that are actually made by
people with deep histories those are the
burgers that you need to eat also you
ready for this one we're gonna go deep
literally deep deep fried burger I'm
sure a deep-fried burger sounds like
some kind of stunt burger but actually
no this burger has DNA that goes all the
way back to the beginning the dawn of
the burger ages in the beginning there
were no flat tops if you want to cook a
burger you had to get a skillet and a
meat cooking the skillet there was no
way for the grease the rendered beef fat
to go anywhere during a busy lunch hour
the cooks would not have time to drain
off the rendered beef fat so they
inadvertently invented an incredible
method of deep frying burgers you can
still walk into a place and find a
skillet with beef tallow in it like
dyers in Memphis they had a very
specific method and it was deep-frying
but they would deep-fry a paper paper
thin piece of raw beef places like dyers
have a big piece of marble in the back
when they smash out their burgers and
this is actually just a piece from Home
Depot this is very important that you're
careful with grease I'm using peanut oil
the temperature you want is right around
325 degrees
there's a lot of water content in beef
and the minute that water content hits
the oil it's gonna explode anything
about 400 degrees could be in trouble
let's help my hair got like this but
they do a dyers in Memphis is very
important they take the spatula
big wide flat spatula first they dip it
into the hot oil number one and they
actually do this and they get they put a
lit of grease on the surface first they
drop a ball of beef and they use a
mallet if they have it like a wooden
mallet and they press out the beef so
it's paper-thin look at brick layer then
you have to gently get this thing off of
here and slip it into the oil oh [ __ ]
here we go that's it what's really cool
about this process deep-frying a burger
is lightning fast this will be done in a
matter of seconds look at that it's
already done can't tell if it's done if
it's obviously crispy and brown around
the edges I'm wearing protective gear as
you can see we may want to wear goggles
obviously this is kind of dangerous now
watch this this is a very cool it's a
very cool method they do a dyers to get
the cheese on the burner and they
actually do is they put the cheese right
on there
and they give it a nice slow dip back
into the grease okay slice of onion some
pickles I'm gonna make a double
[Music]
oh whoa never said wipeout condiments
are not we're not talking about bacon
and lettuce and mayonnaise and
everything else in the beginning it was
really just mustard onion and pickle at
the beginning was really just onion the
deep-fried burger one of the original
American hamburgers it still can be
found in certain spots in the Midwest
mmm oh my God look at that see that
critias crispy bits or that we're be
getting there give that go deep like the
deep-fried burger see that look at those
little crispy bits Oh mmm that's
happiness that is happiness
right there Oh hot crunchy the raw onion
is crunchy the pickles the melted cheese
melted by grease Oh
[Music]
Hey you'd think this would be like a
real grease bomb it's just so food
grease it's actually not as greasy as
you'd think
no reser then cooking out a flattop all
right little more greasy than cooking on
a grill out for sure
hello don't talk about biting into
history you go to Memphis go to dyers
they apparently have not changed the
grease
this is 1912 I'm George Motz I'll see
you next time make more burgers
one last time how's my hair